le marché de l'art pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale et le thème de la
nouvelle exposition au mémorial de la
shoah un marché florissant au même
moment où des oeuvres été volé pillé
confisqué par l'occupant volés par les
seigneurs du rail voici et lingots d'or
et la blood omen les tableaux étaient
volées aux musées français mais aussi
directement confisquées dans les
appartements des français de confession
juive d'allemagne était devenue la
caverne d'ali baba
mais avec beaucoup plus de quarante
voleurs joli monde paiera au lendemain
de la guerre sur les cent mille oeuvres
d'art dérobés soixante mille ont été
récupérés en allemagne et 95% d'entre
elles ont été rendus à leurs
propriétaires
mais certains tableaux de maîtres
restaurant folin exposées dans les
musées français sans propriétaire
pendant 50 ans le style ans jusqu'en
1995 où ce discours va faire bouger les
lignes
oui la folie criminelle de l'occupant a
été chacun le sait second départ des
français seconde et par l'état français
pour la première fois un président de la
république reconnaît la responsabilité
de l'état français dans le génocide juif
deux ans plus tard le premier ministre
met en place un groupe de travail pour
faire l'inventaire des biens spoliés sur
les conditions dans lesquelles des biens
immobiliers ou immobiliers appartenant à
des juifs de nationalité française ou
résidant en france ont été confisqués
aussi bien par l'occupante par les
autorités de vichy
je veux que la lumière soit faite
la commission mattéoli va fouiller les
archives afin de faire l'inventaire
bilan plus de cinquante ans après la
guerre il reste deux mille oeuvres de
valeur sans propriétaire des expositions
de ses tableaux et sculptures vont être
mises en place
le but retrouver les propriétaires ou
leurs ayants droits oeuvres d'art
cherche propriétaire celle annonce que
passe le musée des beaux-arts de dijon
seize oeuvres volées pour la plupart à
des familles juives durant la seconde
guerre mondiale se trouvent en dépôt au
musée
en plus de ces expositions les 2000
oeuvre appelée mnr pour musées nationaux
récupération sont catalogués sur
internet reste aux descendants des
propriétaires a prouvé que ses tableaux
appartenait bien à leurs aïeux depuis
cinq ans alain monteagle a une obsession
amassés dans son grenier tous les
documents sur la collection de son
arrière grand tante et de son mari anna
et john jaffe de riches collectionneurs
installé à nice avant guerre depuis
octobre 2018
la commission pour l'indemnisation des
victimes de spoliations a vu ses
pouvoirs élargis
le but proposer des restitutions ou des
indemnisations notamment lorsque ces
biens ont été confiés à des musées
nationaux
[Musique]